What is mortgage?
You don't have to be a rocket scientist to figure it out.
It's an interest based Reba.
I don't have money to buy this bottle.
I go to the bank and they say to me
you can get this bottle for an X amount of money
which you pay us on installments and we don't have it.
We don't possess it.
We gonna buy it for you for the next amount of money
and add to that our interest.
Sometimes the interest
it fluctuates and it increases according to the um
interest rate of fluctuation rates and inflation and the likes.
So this is clear RIBA.
The vast majority of scholars of all times and of all locations say
it's haram. Only a minority
who came to this land and found that we have to have a house.
Why?
Everybody has a house. Why wouldn't I have a house?
I'd like to have a house for my kids from.
So they jumped the wagon and they started giving fat was left,
right and centre that's halal.
Some of them come and say well
if it is the first house is halal business no.
Wow. Why is that?
Because it's a necessity. It's the first house.
It's okay. So I tell people okay
I came all the way from Saudi alone without a wife and I'm in heat.
I'm desperate. So
could you find me the first time a one night stand?
This is Haram River is even Worse than Zina.
What are you talking about?
So what, what's,
what's, uh,
an analogy? What's the logic?
There's no logic. Haram is Haram.